good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everybody had a splendid refreshing and
truly glorious weekend and if you didn't
that's too bad because it's monday and
we gotta get back to work we've gotta
get back to work i'm sorry to tell you
guys i don't know if you knew already
but it is monday and that just never
gets easier to swallow no that's such a
good point like it is monday and some
people might have not known that until
we told them and you guys know it is our
job here to tell you what day of the
week it is when it is that day when it
is saturday and how we're going to make
it through the week so that's what we're
here to do we're here to make it through
the week but you know what
another amazing weekend i think that
we're gonna make it through this week
let me tell you why just this is my this
is my guest okay i think we're all still
riding high off the announcement of my
tour like we all got our tickets some of
us missed out on tickets some shows sold
out like we're all freaking it's
exciting you know our blood is pumping
tickets available girljob.com
tomorrow
we have a big merch launch like we have
our insanely gorgeous
insanely gorgeous claudia is wearing the
reissued tmt sorority sweatshirt so last
week i wore the old one that i've had
for three years this is the new one so
you can see how it's pigmented how it's
not been torn apart by the washing
machine yet how it's so stunning the
pink is so pliny it's everything of the
sort you need it for fall i actually
read the cutest comment yesterday that
someone commented on our picture where i
was wearing that sweatshirt she said she
found that sweatshirt at goodwill and so
she googled the morning toast and now
she's a toaster don't you just love
don't you i'm assuming she's chosen
because she commented but
don't you love to see that you know
literally that is such a crazy story
right who the [ __ ] sends our sweatshirt
to goodwill i don't know but it's free
marketing thank you okay anyways i am
wearing this new sweatshirt that says
toasty it's perfect for fall so cozy as
champagne glasses on the arms it comes
with matching shorts but since i'm a big
pregnant lady and it's freezing those
shorts were just not happening for me
today and mostly because not because the
shorts don't fit they fit totally fine
it's just as i can't be bothered to
shave my legs so it's also really cold
like you would be insane if you wear
shorts today no shorts for me but the
set is so cute it's perfect for winter
like just for a cozy fall vibe you need
it and also launching homeware glassware
and iphone accessories um you've shown
us your iphone
um we're 13. so we've got all the sizes
you guys don't worry about it this is
the sorority sweatshirt but in a case
and then we've got this tumbler that
i've been secretly not so subtly using
for like the last six months and i'm
just obsessed so we're finally selling
these on tuesday everything is dropping
at shopmorningtoast.com we uh jackie you
wore the um one of our new crewnecks on
friday yes and it's like thursday
thursday yeah and then tomorrow the
everything drops and we'll be wearing
more things also we have two cropped
t-shirts dropping that are so cute
because you know sometimes you just need
a t-shirt i actually need it i don't own
like t-shirts period i'm always wearing
like a sweater so i'm very much looking
forward to incorporating these t-shirts
into my wardrobe they're like the
perfect they say they say tmt and like
the sorority letters on it they're just
like perfect to wear under a blazer or
something you know you just need a
t-shirt well what i was going to say is
like yes we are launching two t-shirts
but unfortunately both of the hosts
refused to model them no because they're
cropped i'm gonna wear it tomorrow i
just forgot to take it home with me i'm
i'm cool with the crop i could be
bumping well have you well you've never
seen
friends but towards the end of rachel's
pregnancy she's pregnant for like
literally six years she starts walking
around in a crop top cute yeah i mean
kylie's doing it that's true they're not
that crop they're like to the belly
button yeah so that's really exciting
they drop at 10 a.m tomorrow
shopmorningtoast.com as always you know
there is
we have a lot of quantity but it is a
limited lot of quantity so if you want
something and you know that you want it
i would hop on early to make sure that
you have an alarm yeah 10 a.m
eastern time shopmorningtoast.com
and then continuing on with our exciting
week of exciting tings
wednesday we'll be in studio will be
being fabulous but what you might not
realize is that that is my last show of
the week and don't worry i'm not leaving
you guys like i did because i already
just took a week off but you know she
forgot to put it in for pt i forgot to
put him for pto because i don't know if
anyone else is struggling with like so
many weddings like i don't know how i'm
supposed to organize my calendar like
have a job when it's literally wedding
wedding wedding bridal shower
bachelorette like all this coved backup
i'm sorry i did drop the ball but you
know what the toasters
ultimately benefit so wednesday will be
my last show i'm going to rome but
thursday friday and monday ben is going
to be filling in for me in studio so
it'll be fun and exciting like ben yes
so we're really like
definitely going to make it through this
week i've never been more sure i guess
when you think about it that way it
makes the week a little bit more
exciting more palatable
from the vantage point of this monday
you know
yeah because it's a monday monday it was
such a nice cozy weekend it's just
gorgeous waking up this morning it was
like still one of those like cozy
it's getting darker like later into the
morning and you just don't want to get
out of bed but i had a really great
relaxing weekend so i'm here i'm feeling
i'm feeling as good as can be on monday
of course i mean i had a hectic [ __ ]
morning i literally rolled over and it
was 9 52
and i like ran screaming and that's
crazy i just ran i'm like why the [ __ ]
did you wake me up he was just sitting
in the living room yeah it's like oh i
thought you were like doing makeup like
check like and you know what now that i
think about it it's ben's fault
obviously whose fault is it gonna be
mine theos the thing is is like and what
i really thought about i used to
oversleep all the time like for like
college and just like life but i don't
think i've really overslept once
in the couple years we've been doing the
show no i think that you have but it's
never been like so bad that like you
missed the show or something like you
know it's never been after 10 30 but oh
no of course not there's been like and i
i have also like sometimes like missed
my alarm and you get here on time but
you're just like chaotic no i literally
was asleep not even 30 minutes ago like
i'm a zombie that's really crazy and
that feeling when you're like you roll
over and me it said 952 and your whole
body just like shakes it's the worst
thing in the world and that feeling felt
so far into me like i really haven't
done that in years you needed the sleep
i'm glad you got your z's 100 i needed
to sleep as opposed to like my husband's
alarm going off when it was still dark
out
and i know he didn't get up when it was
like what
did you set alarms for the middle of the
night that's what you're doing these
days it was just [ __ ] with my rem
cycle
not cool disgusting and like think about
brew what if brew heard that
his whole day is ruined um so obviously
we have an amazing show for you guys
real house has a potomac and salt lake
city we're on and we're going to recap
it at the end but i did want to say i
too had a relaxing weekend i watched
impeachment okay i am gonna file a
motion i'm finally spoiling nope that's
not the motion i'm filing a motion
to move all tv recaps to the end of the
show for people who haven't watched yet
aren't going to watch don't care spoiler
alerts
etc you read a couple podcast reviews
and you've been acting so different and
honestly no i'm not giving in i'm not no
but it makes sense
some people don't want to hear about
impeachment no the thing is like the the
stuff that we put in the tv recap is
very much reality based and i think like
the scripted part of the show is always
at the beginning and i think it's fine
okay i just i saw that comment and it
made sense to me and i'm saying like we
must stop living for the comments like
not living for the comments but i i
don't believe in like reading all
comments and just dismissing them all as
negative and unconstructive no
for sure i take but i don't think that
like okay maybe you would prefer it this
way but it's not like destructive to the
show no way for me to talk about
impeachment now versus in 40 minutes no
it's not but like i also watched younger
this weekend i would like to talk about
it right and but there is a tv segment
in which we can talk about that tv
segment is like so already built
out do you know what i mean and like
usually by the time we're done recapping
housewives like we don't even want to
talk about the thing we wanted to talk
about at the beginning we're just like
oh yeah like i watch impeachment it was
great like you know okay i mean
you guys will obviously weigh in here
and let us know what you think today you
can have it your way i just don't i
think you really need to stop reading
the podcast i don't read them that often
no you read them once and everything
changed like we couldn't sing anymore
our loud songs we had to move the tv
recap to the back like there was
something else too like who cares like
this is our show people this is our show
a lot of people care you're gonna you
can talk about impeachment today and you
guys let us know i think it does it
makes sense in the order of things i
think yes on the surface it makes sense
but when it comes into actually
executing it like by the end of the show
we're like mentally exhausted and like
okay we'll just have to get through
housewives like we're not thinking
clearly at the end of the show i think
it's important for people to know that
before they put their input in okay
you guys well impeachment is
unbelievably good it's so annoying
because there's six episodes out and
there's going to be 10 total so like me
and ben were so into it and then we were
like what
so that was frustrating now i have two
things to say
well i do think beanie feldstein did a
great job
i do not think it was the role for her
like she's
first of all she doesn't really look
like monica she just has bangs
and everyone else looks exactly like the
linda trip i had to look up what linda
tripp looked like
sarah paulson is incredibly talented one
because she looks just like linda tripp
and two i didn't know linda tripp
personally i don't know anything about
her but if like
if she is like what sarah paul said made
her out to be like she's the most
annoying human being on the [ __ ]
planet sarah paulson really has that
effect on her characters
she's perfect for it yeah yes she plays
like hateable figures
or is she just hateable good question we
don't know um also what's so crazy is
like i honestly know very very little
about the monica lewinsky thing because
it was when i was you were three years
old yeah
so for me i feel like i'm watching like
a totally fictional series and it's like
what's gonna happen next even though
most people probably know what happens
next like i know literally nothing like
i don't even know about that guy like in
the clinton administration like killed
himself like i didn't know any of this
so it's all just like it's all really
happening for me
but what's so crazy is like it really
wasn't that long ago so so many of the
people who they meet when they're
traversing around dc like still working
like jake tapper was like you know some
guy she met at a bar like there's so
many people who are like we still know
they're like famous in politics and like
they're literally in the show so that's
just like crazy because it feels so far
away but it's like not at all yeah
um
so yes i was actually very curious like
whose story are we telling you know is
this monica's story is it linda tripp's
story is it bill's story like whose
story is it and so i did monica's story
so i did see that monica was involved
with ryan murphy like i i just wanted to
know i'm sure you know everyone
perceived experienced the thing
differently like the scandal so who's
and we're taking monica to side and
honestly like justice for [ __ ] monica
it's so sad like it's
okay whatever the only other problem i
had with the show i don't know i'm
complaining a lot but i did actually
really like it is
um bill clinton is like
butt ugly like no one can deny that like
in real life oh my god i don't know who
the man is who's playing him but like he
is handsome and he's doing the whole job
like
a little too well because i'm like yes
bill and like bill clinton is not hot
like bill clinton today
no even when he was president are you
sure you looked at pictures of course
and he wasn't like you know
gorgeous but he was
he wasn't like heinous but he wasn't
gorgeous and this guy who's playing him
oh my god he's
so hot like and he's like so
presidential you know yeah um so i do
feel like that's factually inaccurate
um and i just like my shows to be more
accurate historically and also like
where is hillary like eddie falco plays
hillary she's in one scene in the
bathroom in the first episode she
doesn't say one where she just washes
her hands and walks out and then
literally like last night's episode she
was like sleeping in the bed and we
didn't see her like where's hillary i
mean that kind of tracks she she wasn't
yeah i know i'm sure that like this is a
this is a big stain on her life that's
true i'm sure the people who are writing
the show would like to keep her out of
it yeah well
she's there and edie falco looks just
like her yeah like crazy like or maybe
she pops up in the last four episodes i
have them all rewarded like i'm gonna
i'm i don't wanna experience what you
experienced i wanna watch all ten even
though i feel like it might be a lot to
watch all at once like i remember when i
watched the last american crime story
o.j simpson and i watched every week but
it felt like the whole country was
watching every week so you know that was
a fun activity for all of us it was just
like a lot to digest every week and you
kind of needed the week to
sit with it like i couldn't just like
bang them out no i watched oj in one
sitting it wasn't a bangable show i
don't think that you did because we
watched it at the same time i didn't
want you episodically at all
i think i maybe started watching when
like the second to last episode
premiered
interesting i hate watching things
weekly like it just it grinds my gears
so the fact that i have now a whole
month left of impeachment yeah it's
disgusting yeah no i i won't make that
mistake it's a mistake for sure what
happens is i'm like okay i'll wait for
it to
be done and then i never watch it oh of
course yeah so if you weren't talking
about it i could see myself not watching
impeachment but i do want to watch it
because again we were two and four years
old so
i have we don't know anything we don't
know anything it was it's really good
yeah you know ryan murphy is just great
yeah um and you watch younger i did
watch you you want to save it for the
end or you want to talk about it now
because you mean you could choose you
could just script it in the beginning
unscripted at the end okay
um i watched younger because i always
used to watch and then i remember i
started the second to last season a year
ago and it was
far too dumb and i was like i can't
watch this and i guess you know the bar
is lower because i enjoyed it immensely
things have changed things have changed
i mean paris has come out right no like
the bar has just been lowered and
it was enjoyable it's a cute show like
and there are some really funny moments
like there were some times i was
laughing out loud and i love like debbie
mazar and lauren's character and diana
trout even though she's not in the last
season what the [ __ ] was that they
bumped up lauren
yes and they gave her all of diana's
scenes but still so it made it okay but
still like justice for diana trout did
she gets a better job like i don't maybe
she just like couldn't work because of
covid and like it was a very coveted oh
yeah zayn broke up with her over
facebook never to be heard from again
like i was just like okay coven and also
it was sad to watch this last season
because like the world they they didn't
you know address covet at all the world
that they're living in the new york that
they're living in doesn't exist like
these fabulous people going into offices
just like having lunch you know jumping
on the subway to get here oh let me come
see your gallery in the middle like
nobody does that [ __ ] anymore like it's
just an unfabulous city and so it was a
little bittersweet to be watching it
because it was like damn those were the
days
um
and i enjoyed it like still
some of the [ __ ] that they do on that
show like kelsey should have been fired
20 times over same for lies like when
kelsey sent her spoiler alert tits to
her instagram story like when they just
got funding from an investment group in
chicago who she all told them to follow
her on social media like
i'm sorry yeah fired
fired she didn't even get fired though
she just got demoted and so she was like
i've lost everything and it's like no
you you should actually no like you
still have your job like that's way more
than most people got i guess it's like
jeffrey toobin like just got suspended
for showing his wiener but the thing is
is like with that show is the
the you like
sorry i'm literally like having a brain
fart oh my god
so i just really felt like she was just
it's so crazy it was crazy to me that
she's in publisher to begin with like of
course like it's just so stupid yeah
okay that's what i was gonna say like
you can only like go along with
something being so stupid for so long
until it becomes glaringly obvious like
how unrealistic a certain setting is so
so unrealistic like i just
there were so many things that were just
like bothering me but on the whole it's
and also like now that i'm a reader
actually the last time i watched younger
i wasn't it was pre-reading pre-kindle
so now that i'm a reader i'm like
immensely interested in like the
publishing aspect and it's like all they
would publish is like this if this
famous person's writing a book like what
about the all the other books that
aren't like celebrity memoirs you know
what i mean like you're right i only
ever took meetings with like
already famous famous people well that
was the point of incubator
yeah no and that's and i appreciated the
incubator and i thought that was really
good idea it was like patreon and like
then i'm like okay this show hits it on
the head right like they get the current
digital climate yes so
that like so things like that are
redeeming the episode with fupa
the um she was like fake greta toonberg
oh my god that was so [ __ ] funny it
was so funny so like there were so many
moments where i was genuinely laughing
out loud and then there was others just
that are just so cringe yeah and the
fact that in the end the spoiler alert
liza ends up with josh i mean i'm a
chizestant obviously
and
they were so close
and i just i disagree my god she was
pissed me off so [ __ ] much at the end
like after all charles did for you like
all he wanted to do is get married like
he's not asking you for the crazy thing
like just [ __ ] marry the man yeah no
it's it was really infuriating
i'm sorry to say like that was really
it's like harry ending up with aidan and
the fact that debbie and these are
maggie i can never remember her
character i'm just like debbie the fact
that she like ends up with the woman who
canceled her um heather mooney
from romeo michelle yeah yeah oh my god
she mentioned the quick burning paper i
didn't even realize that but like
that she's falling in love with a woman
who canceled her i'm just it was so
thrown together at the end like yeah i
it was not thoughtful in any way no but
it was still it was good and for like a
coveted ending i feel like we got
everything i didn't feel like we
missed out on anything other than like
zayn and kelsey yeah and like the fact
the fact that kelsey was living in a
two-bedroom apartment with three people
total and a baby while she was publisher
of empirical press
um no
no
no no no and then when she finally said
you know what i'm gonna move out i've
been saving up and she still won't just
like move into a [ __ ] rental there's
a million in the city she has to like
move into this building that this guy
she's been dating for two weeks owns
like that's the worst idea i've ever
heard like you have terrible judgment i
mean i literally watch the show so long
ago like i don't even remember
everything you're talking about so she
like remembers she starts dating
claire's ex yeah and he's a real estate
developer so when she needs to leave the
apartment because claire got mad at her
for dating her ex she moves into the the
model apartment in his building it's
like
get your own [ __ ] apartment you were
a publisher that's like being [ __ ]
anna wintour and living with three
roommates yeah totally higher than that
because she's not even head of conde
nest totally i'm so like i'm sorry so
that's
that's how i feel so like it's over and
it was a good show i know and you know
what i i spent all day saturday and
friday night watching it and it was like
exactly what i needed exactly it was
always like a fun stupid light show like
yeah it was just what the doctor ordered
so that was fun then i finished the book
i was reading party crasher by sophie
kinsella you know she's my favorite
author
it was my least favorite so we can sell
a book there has to be one just the
protagonist was just like not my kind of
girl okay she was not like other girls
but not in the same same way as us
oh yeah
and then i started a new book yesterday
called this tender land by william kent
krueger it's like a very it's a novel
you know dana it's a dana's choice
recommendation
she said it was like the best book ever
so and so many redheads did too so i'm
like 40 of the way and it is really good
but it's it's a lot so that's been nice
it was a good content week and for me
considering i feel like i've had a few
failed like honestly like a failed month
outlander and i'm not going back to
outlander you guys because i took a
little break and then i realized i
didn't miss it and i didn't miss the way
that it made me feel yeah and i was
planning on starting made this weekend
but from what i'm hearing it's like so
emotionally triggering like i actually
don't i'm in a good head space like i
don't really want to bring myself
to that level wait okay i watched maid
and i finished it and it was a lot and
as i said it was very intense it's a lot
to sit with i prefer to watch it when
the sun was out because it was just too
much when the sun went down
i enjoyed it immensely i thought it was
it's a true story which always i think
makes it a better story and
i would i would recommend it it was
productive viewing
margaret quali's such a star and and
that way if you watch it i wouldn't have
to always be like convincing you of her
star power yeah and she stars in it with
andy mcdougall who is her mom they play
mother and daughter
mcdowell yeah yeah they played mother
and daughter in the show and their
mother and daughter in real life and
they're both fantastic actresses so that
was just like an
acting nugget of cuteness i love like
having little like nuggets like things
that you know yeah i just don't think i
can do it like i'm i'm finally in like a
positive headspace it's fall like why
would i do that okay so you could wait
but it was it's really really good
really well done and
i would recommend it but just like i was
watching only two episodes today it's
not something like that
yeah because the episodes are like
[ __ ] movies they're an hour
impeachment they're all like an hour
crazy they're making like movies no i
felt the same way about downton abbey
since like every scene was like filled
with so much dialogue and sets and
outfits i'm like this is an hour like
sometimes an hour 15 hour 30 minute
episode i'm like you're just making
movies yeah no for me i was like i've
watched 10 movies right
crazy yeah
okay and that's the content the scripted
because the script stay tuned for the
unscripted coming at you soon don't get
it twisted i mean kravis is engaged like
we just have to get to it we have to get
to it go ahead without oh my go ahead go
ahead me because without further ado it
is time for the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
curology excuse me curology customizes a
prescription formula with three active
ingredients picked out for you to help
tackle your skin care needs whether that
may be trying to take control of acne or
if acne no longer is your top skin
concern you can also address fine lines
dark spots occasional breakouts or
clogged pores you start by answering
questions online about your skin and if
it's a good fit then curology will match
you with a licensed dermatology provider
who will get to know your skin and
subject to consultation you'll get a
customized prescription cream to be
shipped straight to your door to address
your acne fine lines dark spots or more
so it's actually a really in-depth um
questionnaire that you fill out you
submit pictures of your face it really
feels like they're getting to know your
skin from the inside out and i've been
using curology for a while now and i
have to say the moisturizer that they
sent me i said this to jackie the other
day it's hands down the best facial
moisturizer i've ever used like it's
it's like a gel like it's really creamy
it's just a gel i love it gel it's
fabulous so if you feel like you have
specific needs my skin can be dry
i have a lot of oil builds up in my nose
and my chin like
they're going to address your problems
which is fabulous because you have
different problems than me um you can
start your curology journey just like i
did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com toast if prescribed just
pay five dollars for shipping and
handling that's c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
curology.com toast to unlock your free
30-day trial where you can cancel
anytime go get that glow
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
doing business with you
first story so exciting kravis engaged
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are engaged they got engaged last night
in montecito california where travis
popped the question at the rosewood
miramar beach hotel surrounded by an
elaborate display of red roses and white
candles
followed by what seemed to be like a
little par-tay with the family
okay
so
i don't really know where we should
start here i think let's start first of
all okay they've been together since the
beginning of the year like not that long
but it does feel like this like kismet
astrological like soulmate thing um so i
don't feel like it's too soon i really
don't like i feel like they've known
each other forever he's been on the
kardashians like a couple times in the
last like 10 years i think that the
timing is fine i think the timing is
fine they've been dating about nine
months and i think you know if this were
my friend i would say maybe that's fast
but like for courtney is so not a hasty
person like she was dating scott for 20
years and still wasn't ready like i
think she knows herself well enough to
know when she's ready and that she's
ready i agree so even though i was when
i first saw they were engaged i was like
how long has it been a year right but i
have complete and other utter faith in
these two and their relationship like
it's yes it's very filled with lust but
they also have a blended family and
they're it's so much deeper than
just like the instagram pics that they
post that's true and so i
believe i think this is so beautiful and
i think the fact that like courtney is
so down and and for this one like we
just assumed she wasn't like a marriage
girl forever but no it's just she was a
travis girl right and you know what's so
weird because there's been so many
kardashian relationships and weddings
courtney's never been married like when
you think of like
hollywood you think someone getting
married it seems like oh yeah whatever
like this is travis's third marriage
like but for courtney like she's never
done it so like it seems so real but
yeah that's how you like you know even
more so that it's real that you can just
you you can go with courtney on this one
so then the second element worth
discussing is a scott of it all because
scott was very much wanting to marry
courtney as we saw many times on the
show and she
very firmly said like i don't want to
get married maybe i don't want to get
married to you or i don't want to get
married period but everyone is now like
where's scott
yeah i mean and also because i just for
a number of reasons one a year ago she
was saying to him like you need to do
these things and if you do like if you
do then we can be together and he didn't
do them so like i can't feel that bad
for him
i need to know what those things are
before i die yeah i like i absolutely
remember 100
two like knowing that him and sophia
didn't work out because he was always
you know had one foot in courtney's
house and now sophia is in like a really
serious relationship she like moved in
with her boyfriend they bought a house
together and it's like where does this
leave scott and he doesn't even have an
amelia to
ring up in this time of need well you
know what like maybe this could be a
moment for him to be like maybe i should
stop dating children maybe that's why it
hasn't worked out yeah so of course like
i and i i'm i do
like scott so i you know i hope he's
okay and i think he's fine because he
was at snl last week i'm sure someone
gave him the heads up that this was
happening well so
yes that's the third thing i wanted to
talk about do you feel like this is so
kind of out of character for courtney
like
such a public moment first of all like
on a public beach like people it got
blown up on social media before they
even got to post about it so public so
big so grand and then like filming for
the show filming the the dinner i felt
like it was kind of out of character for
courtney who you know her boundaries yes
but i just feel like when you're like
courtney i believe is so happy like
circle is complete for her she's
feeling amazing so like sometimes your
walls come down a little bit and maybe
in those times when she had them up so
hives because like she was wanting to
keep people out she had stuff that she
didn't want to share it's very personal
but like in her joy i think she's just
like sure sure it's just different and i
think even though this like seems so big
for us you know it's not kanye proposing
at the no at the stadium but even though
at the stadium that was still more
private yeah but nobody it's just like a
beautiful beach site at their favorite
hotel proposal on like the day they got
back from new york so she probably
wasn't expecting it like she might have
been in her airplane clothes
and i think it was just natural which
she is a natural girly so i saw a lot of
people online saying this and i agree
with that more than your gorgeous theory
um that they might have been been
engaged in like kind of private real
moment um and then with this new show
then i'm sure is paying them much more
courtney has has to participate um then
they decided to kind of give a moment
for the show but their initial
engagement was probably like a more
personal
private moment
okay
that's what i think
okay i mean even still if it was like a
a different courtney she wouldn't give
it to the show she and she and she might
have even been like i think family might
have even been like okay you know you're
in we're not gonna film your proposal
like that's fine we'll talk about
engagement tomorrow well i actually
think that with this new hulu deal i do
think the dynamic probably has shifted
quite a bit because with the e-show it
was like this burden where
they weren't making that much money from
it's like no one wanted to go out of
their way to do it with this brand new
hulu deal
i'm sure they're making
10 times more of what they were making
that would mean that they're making a
billion dollars for 10 seasons is it 10
is it a 10 season deal no that's what
i'm saying the original deal was 10
seasons so i'm sure what they probably
made send on for one maybe two i think
that what they're getting paid per
episode is probably literally ten times
more but they were getting paid on e so
everyone kind of got their [ __ ] together
especially courtney if you like if you
want to accept that deal we're gonna
split the money with you like you gotta
work right but then when you think about
it that way to me that seems like the
antithesis of courtney like sell it like
thinking about her relationship in terms
of like the
what the show is paying her i think
they're just two separations
yeah no like you gotta work so like
she's selling her relationship to the
show no but that's why i'm saying
if she had a private one first and then
this like kind of out of character very
public thing was like for the show
i don't know i
i think it's just you know
they're in love and they're not looking
around like and it is what it is and
it's it's beneficial for everyone that
it's filmed and because she's happy like
she's letting us into her life
i think
i believe my theory well it's not my
theory i saw it on the internet but i
think that there was probably because
when i saw it i'm like there's no way
because it's like
it's so public but i guess the
relationship also has been so public
this far like so much pda like they
really have been like
just very public
doing their thing and the thought of
them like faking a second proposal is so
not courtney to me well honestly if
that's the case it makes me love kravis
like yes you know that the show is
important you're prioritizing your work
maybe courtney can you maybe courtney
will learn from that you know so i i
don't know i kind of hope because that
is like yes kravitz like be a stage mom
let's go yeah
kravis
travis okay i'm like the both of them
yeah no um
yeah no i think it's all so beautiful
the ring is so slow and that's like
another thing i could have seen courtney
with just like a black yes
yeah totally like a tattoo ring right
but like she's just going full fairy
tale and
this is what she's been waiting for so
it kind of tracks like just it just was
never right before you know but now
we're seeing a whole new woman a woman
in love really no she has had the most
twisted dating history like
didn't she like date justin bieber for a
minute like she
has finally landed where she was meant
to land and you just love to see it yeah
so this is very exciting of course can't
wait for the show to come out it's going
to be like a year or so i know they all
uh oh but kim did say i i forget what
show she was on
she gave very little insight but she did
say like they're gonna have a much
faster turnaround time on this show like
how we're always complaining how we're
watching things on the kardashians that
happened a year ago like we're on to a
new scandal like that's so sure and also
like when you think about the demilio
show which is also on hulu it was like
just a few months in between right so
that's really exciting that is very
exciting he could never
yeah okay well
mazel tov
to kravis
i look forward like courtney is a bride
she'll definitely wear a black wedding
dress totally like the fact that she was
wearing like a full black black to like
her engagement is iconic she didn't even
take her sunglasses off good no but like
look
that's a little exciting yeah what you
got to do i can't wait to see the
photographer pictures yeah
anyways i really liked how they did it
they just got me like normal people and
it's beautiful um
machine gun kelly and megan fox are like
quaking because like they're like well
we have to be the better emo couple like
they're gonna get engaged in like a
month you think so totally
shanna moekler like posted something on
her stories like
like that she needed a break or
something like
sad because you know all of her kids are
now like posting like coordinating the
love of you like that sucks oh okay i
thought for a second shannon oklahoma
burgess chardonnay jackie me too i get
them so confused that's
really confusing yeah because it's like
the same thing with megan
and brian austin green okay i just i
can't so she my brain can only retain so
much all the kids landed in alabama
travis's and
shauna sharna
no shannon
shannon oakland shadow mogler all their
kids were there like with the
kardashians posting like we're so happy
were you like if i was shanna mochler
like i would need a break too yeah
that's really just like the worst case
scenario you know your ex is marrying
the most famous woman in the most famous
family your kids love her love their
kids they're gonna like move in together
blended but london now are you glad that
you watched courtney she know she was
like always starting those like really
cute movie nights in her backyard like
she needs to have a family screening of
blended i know but it already seems like
they are blended they don't they could
star in the sequel
wow okay it pains me but we have to move
on to our next story which is some
the opposite of happy couple news
but it's bad couple speculation okay
okay
lala can't i love when you go into
denial mode like for your favorite
couples no but i'll tell you why i'm
holding out i'll tell you why lala kent
removes randall emmett from instagram
sparks break up rumors lala ken has fans
wondering whether she and fiance randall
have split after she either deleted or
archived all the photos she had of him
from her instagram the vanderpump real
star also posted a video to her
instagram story of two male friends
walking through a hotel one rolling a
suitcase in the other pushing her baby
ocean set to the extremely telling song
sorry by beyonce
so
also there are some rumors floating that
like randall was spotted with some
ladies in a hotel and an elevator on
multiple occasions
so
our lala and randall separated the only
thing i want to say is in the past lala
has deleted all pictures of randall from
her instagram she's done it once maybe
even twice like where it's like are they
broken up what happened and she says
like it's not has nothing to do with
their actual relationship she just sort
of gets like
spooked about just like having it all
over social media so but there's also a
lot of other things going on here so i
don't know what's up what's a lot of
other the literal photos of randall like
walking through the lobby
yeah walking through the lobby of hotel
with like two blonde girls and the video
of her of lala checking into a hotel
like there's more here okay well she's
at like the beverly hills hotel so maybe
she has a photo shoot just gonna set
that one aside you saw photos of randall
two of him walking through a hotel lobby
was he holding hands nobody got into an
elevator with the girl with one girl
yeah
and then i think in the other one there
was two guys you don't know that they
were just strangers
passing in the night they weren't they
weren't wearing masks so like they were
in the elevator together
so
if they're vaccinated no but like if
you're in the elevator with strangers
like that's when you put your masks on
maybe not for them
maybe in new york denial you want but
there's something going on i think
there's just a path here to where you
know if there's not much going on like i
don't think they're gonna break up but i
do think there's something going on
they can't break up what about ocean i
know but like why can't randall just
keep it in his pants but we don't know
that he didn't
i'm choosing to show you the pictures
oh my god okay i just need to see for
myself okay i mean it's going to take me
a minute hang on okay
oh this is just not the news you want to
hear this morning especially as the
show's airing because then it's like we
can't even enjoy
the show knowing what's coming
i think it was on reddit oh it's okay if
you can't find it i'll find them later i
can send them to you later but i didn't
see them like floating around crazy
you should tell me later okay
i mean this is obviously sad because
there are a couple we stand
but i just don't think it's
beneficial for anyone for us to just be
in denial yeah okay this is what she
said the last time she deleted all the
pictures of him this makes more sense
than what i said in a moment of feeling
protective angry and impulsive i deleted
every photo of him including the moment
we got engaged i felt like what people
were saying was so unfair and i'm the
one that put him out there like that
okay
okay
this could be applied to this situation
too people are saying unfair things
about him and she's the one who put him
out there like that
people are saying unfair things about
him because she deleted the pictures so
she this was the catalyst so make it
make sense
people are saying unfair things about
him because of the pictures that were
seen in nashville and so maybe it's just
like
i don't know
honestly i feel like the pictures of her
i don't know if it's natural don't quote
me on that um i think the pictures of
him in the lobby like i only saw them
after she deleted all the pictures
because she made this whole kerfuffle
damn okay i'm losing i mean obviously i
don't want it to be true either
yeah but like let's live in reality for
a moment
yeah i just can't fathom it being true
right now you know they just had a child
rock solid they're so they're so strong
on the show
i read her book like they're so
simpatico erotico and so
it's just hard to swallow i'm gonna hold
out hope you know me because i don't
give up on my ships at ease i don't i
will not let this ship go down without a
fight
but i will this is literally you i will
go down with this ship
that is me i won't put my hands up
and surrender
there will be no white flag above my
house
i'm in love
and always will be that is literally it
that is literally me i and for the ships
that i
there's a i don't do it for every ship
but for this one i will go down with the
ship
and i also realize that my argument is
losing steam i do realize that okay no i
mean the ship is thinking faster and
faster but it's just we've hit nice now
we've like switched spots like let's
just wait and see what happens
you see how you know no i mean nothing
is definitive but something happens i
was the one who first said when courtney
travis got together that they're
probably just business partners like
right maybe i don't have a good read on
these things you think everyone's going
into business together except wait
the weekend and angelina jolie
it came out that he's now like a u.n um
like working with the un or something
which is like so angelina wait it's very
possible they were in business together
and that they weren't dating that's
amazing
that's one point for me but still i lost
some kravis irena and kanye are in
business together j lo and ben affleck
together honestly jerry's still out
there
oh totally no no but i really thought
they were like working on a male
skincare line right
called
him
right um
so you know
maybe you don't
maybe you don't follow me on this one
but
i have to be able to sleep that night of
course of course of course i totally
never should i just i'm gonna
you know i hate when people rush to
conclusions 100 and you know what i'm
actually going to bump up a story
because our next story is brought to you
but our next story about rushing to
conclusions is brought to you by liquid
iv and look what i think is not approval
for you rushing to conclusions cooler
weather makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body properly
hydrated flu season is in full swing so
proper hydration and vitamins can help
support a strong immune system liquid iv
is here to hydrate you faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins it has more
vitamin c than an orange and it's
healthy and as much potassium as a
banana it's a healthier alternative for
sugary sports drinks it has no
artificial flavors and preservatives and
it has less sugar than an apple so look
what i've earned these amazing little
packs you pop them in your water and
it's literally like taking your water
and tripling it it's just
it's great time management which we're
always advocating here at the morning
toast also you didn't hear from me it is
a fabulous hangover remedy um just
filled with such good things for you
just gotta soak it all up hydrate
and just because it's colder weather
doesn't mean you don't need to be
hydrated grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use the code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get better hydration today using
promo code toast at liquidive.com they
have tons of delicious flavors find your
favorites check it out always have it
stocked in the home it's the perfect
thing for cultivating vibes the perfect
thing okay i cultivated a vibe last
night by the way i saw that you did it
was honestly like like no time had had
passed and i feel like that was the
first time that you had cultivated a
vibe and you just didn't let me know
that you were cultivating a vibe because
like i've got it you've got yeah you've
got it
how was the chili
so good i made it ben okay and i have
leftover and i put a picture of my chili
like up on my
story
and i put like a weird filter on it so i
can make my house look moody and
everyone's like ew your chili looks
gross and i'm like shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] first of all it's delicious and
second of all get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here and you know
what chili is an unphotogenic meal sorry
and you know what the worst it looks
probably the better it tastes
so
don't pay the haters any money i will
not i'm glad you enjoyed ben's home and
i'm like panicking he's going to eat the
leftover chili before i can get home to
it like oh i have to wrap up the show
okay that would explain why you didn't
bring manny i actually cooked a little
something last night i made my own
caesar dressing salad dressing without
eggs because you know most caesar
dressings have raw eggs so you can't
have it when you're pregnant no no i
didn't know that but i had ordered
hillstone and they have an eggless
caesar dressing so i put it in the
fridge because i was like this is good
dressing i'll make a salad
dressing disappears
yeah yeah but i already had it in my
head that i was going to make a salad
who the [ __ ]
blame brew for sure
so i wound up making my own dressing
which i just feel like it's such a
mom it's such a
level
like a a level up in life you know it's
like you get older you settle down you
make your own dress you make your own
dressing and and it was really good so
now i have some in the fridge and i'll
be using my own dress so excited yeah so
that's a really fun fact about me
um okay this next story speaking about
jumping to conclusions because this
really bothered me olivia j g newly is
slamming a rumor that she's hooking up
with dancing with the star's partner
partner i was going to say pal because
his name
so not here for the drama olivia jade
clapbacked after tweak talk users you
know what can i explain the story like i
literally saw the whole thing happen in
real time okay please explain there's
this girl on tick tock who gets like
anonymous no not well she gets people's
like experiences like i met jackie
ashley starbucks and she slapped me in
the face yeah but she then goes on
tick-tock it's funny i don't go to
starbucks right and you're more of a
puncher than a slapper
so and then she will children one tock
is reenact them like in little skits
okay so it's like fun and it's like
she doesn't really try to like hide the
she never says like olivia jade but
she'll be like girl who pretended to row
like she's very obvious in who she's
talking about and in the comments she'll
like the comments of people who guess
right so it's she's not trying to you
know be really anonymous at all okay and
honestly they come up on my for you page
sometimes and it's like
the kind of long-winded and i'm like i
can't get to the end of the story like
it's the longest skit ever so then i saw
the olivia jade one and i knew
immediately who she was talking about
one because she didn't make it difficult
to guess and two like people have been
like saying oh i heard you know olivia
and val are [ __ ] like
so and also like he said she said like
his wife isn't allowed to go to his
trailer right and he's the only one
whose wife is like working on the show
right there might be one more but like
yeah it wasn't hard to guess right okay
so i mean it was just like silly rumor
but like everyone was quaking and this
particular girl's video blew up and
and
she blocked olivia jade right so olivia
jade like went to like do edit and be
like this is just not true she couldn't
even do edit so she just like put a
green screen up it was like a whole it
made the editing process for olivia jade
probably quite treacherous yes but she
just suggested straight on and said i'm
gonna be super blunt and straight up and
say val and i are not hooking up we've
never hooked up this is a complete rumor
we are generally good friends and i
adore his wife and i completely believe
her when i saw that video i was like
there's no way
and it's just like it's really bothers
me that people just go around like
saying these things and like blind items
whatever
and
it's true unless like someone has to
outright deny but then even still like
it's it's floating around there like to
me that video i didn't know that was the
premise of this girl's account i thought
that girl
the way she made it seem i guess she was
reading from the
submitter's perspective but she made it
seem like she works on the set of
dancing with the stars she reads
people's and i'm sorry it's just one of
the losers things
i've ever encountered yeah no i mean i
love that olivia j just outright was
like absolutely not this is not a thing
because i think a lot of people were
thinking it like they're very but that's
all the people that dancing with the
stars you like literally grope your
partner when the things over and over
right you're like you're waiting for the
results and you're grabbing each other's
tits like it's [ __ ] like grinding up
on each other and they're like they're
looking close yeah because they're
[ __ ] grinding so i think that
everyone thinks that especially olivia
jade's like this gorgeous girl like i
think that it's a natural thing to think
but to put it out there like it's fact
what actually it's not i agree like this
age we're living in where people just
kind of post things on social media with
absolutely
not even one morsel of research like how
do you know that this girl even works at
dancing with the stars like
i do not like that and sometimes the
stuff turns out to be true for sure but
sometimes it's just like a flat out lie
yeah that just reminds me of like the
kanye thing with um
the tick tocker
in the hotel
coal something i don't remember who it
was but it was just lies you didn't know
he said he made the whole thing up
there's nothing loserier yeah i agree i
hate that
okay ready for our next story
oprah winfrey will be interviewing adele
in the one night only concert special so
we're getting more tea absolutely
well not not buckingham palace but it's
i you know
i i do feel like might be a conflict of
interest yeah and i saw some oprah
should just go around interviewing
everyone i saw someone say that like
adele's been living in their life for
kobit and she can't go back to uk
because of covet so there's no way she
filmed at buckingham palace i saw
someone say that too but you can travel
to the uk yeah so she could have done
and if like i'm seeing people on
instagram do it adele could do i'm
literally going to rome this week like
right so adele can do it okay oprah
winfrey set to interview adele as part
of a two-hour special welcoming back the
grammy winner from her years-long break
the special will feature an exclusive
interview with adele by oprah from her
rose garden oh i guess that's oprah's
garden yeah or
whatever it's a garden
but is there a performance in the garden
as well
well maybe it's performance garden
performance garden buckingham garden
buckingham garden is it the same garden
where megan and harry were interviewed
no because that was confirmed as not to
be megan and harry's house nor oprah's
house could you imagine if it was going
from buckingham oh yeah that garden i
think that's the bridge that we need
adele adele is the bridge in adele's
first televised wide-ranging
conversation about her new album the
stories behind the songs life after
divorce weight loss and raising her son
adele one night only will also feature
an extraordinary concert performance
that includes the earliest opportunity
to hear her new material in six years
the special is being produced by james
corden and ben winston's full well 73
and onward productions in association
with winfrey's harper harpo productions
i read a funny tweet once i was like
who
what body did james corden help and
hollywood executive bury
to get as far as like he's funny for
sure definitely not everyone likes him
but like his stick is cute or whatever
corporal karaoke
who what is where what did he do how did
he get here i don't know
he must be i mean aside he either buried
a body or he's just like the best guy
ever
because adele also like has gone on
vacation with him like i think people
just like love being around harry styles
loves him and they love burying bodies
with him yes him and like it's so
confusing yeah like adele harpo james
gordon yeah no it's it is pretty wild
but
there was a like now i think my biggest
gripe with james gordon is that he's
just everywhere you know and and then he
doesn't
before he was everywhere like i really
did i really thought he was a talented
guy so i think everybody had that
thought and we're like we should give
him everything yeah he's everywhere we
hate him no and the thing is is like i
wish he would just be more selective
with where he goes because so much of
what he
chooses to do is like flop central cats
mm-hmm
cinderella cinderella i feel like i can
name a thousand things where he's just
floppy oh mm-hmm so you're gonna bring
her into this if you're gonna be
everywhere like you have to be great and
he's just unfortunately not
not always
but he has been
in the past yeah when he was just the
james corden guy like i was loving him
yeah carpool karaoke that used to be
everything now you couldn't [ __ ] pay
me no literally it's so crazy you used
to like wait for the new one and the tv
show they have of it and then like
another another put like fifth harmony
in with like a jonas brother like it's
just too much of a good thing yeah
you know it's a good lesson yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story what was the story we just said
adele oprah oh yeah i feel like we
didn't really kind of massage it enough
but i'm excited i'm excited i think
oprah will be doing the massaging and
we'll be doing the listening yeah it's
gonna be gorgeous do you know if it's
happening after before the album
released it sounds like before because
it will be songs that we hadn't heard
before it'll be the earliest opportunity
to hear the first new material
i kind of would have preferred it to be
after just so i can like learn a few
songs yeah
but watch it at your own pace how much
how many times did you listen to easy on
me this weekend
not that many times because i wasn't
like listening to music i was watching
younger but um i had in my head all
weekend
but i also have found some really good
spotify playlists i guess it's like of
like songs from
you know gen z and stuff that are really
really good so i've just been enjoying
you know like james arthur yeah you know
him yeah so he was on the playlist like
mimi webb
it was just like it was called like
everyday essentials and it was just some
good music and it's been a really long
time since i've just discovered new
songs and artists so i was just like
enjoying their curation well honestly i
know you're so against tick tock but
that's literally how i find out all my
names no i know i know who's really like
coming up as like one of the best gen z
artists
of our time
you're going to be shocked
willow smith
and that's not just shocking i mean like
her music
transparent soul and meet me on our spot
blew up on tick tock and it's like
so good okay i'll add it to my playlist
yeah mimi
well that's actually the perfect segue
for our fifth and final story which is
about tick tock music okay
but
before
we've got to let you know that hold on
what do we have to do are we going full
blast full blast the people weighed in
and they let us know and the the the
negative reviews were overruled
it's the final story
[Music]
[Applause]
okay our fifth and final story the
beatles have an official tick tock now
and you can use their music oh my god in
an apparent bid to infect gen z with
beatlemania the fab four have officially
arrived on tick-tock their handle at the
beatles the iconic rock groups account
has amassed over 180 000 followers since
its creation friday as a promo for the
disney plus documentary get back as well
as the beatles new remixed let it be
album variety reported so
not only will they be on tick tock but
their most iconic tunes are now
available for use on tick tock and i
know all the tick talkers are dying to
have been waiting for this moment and
i'm really happy for them hey jude
don't make it bad
okay like honestly i don't really feel
like the beatles should be on tech talk
like that's just me i'm not like keeping
tick tock i think if they wanted to
upload their music you know organically
organically so people could use the
the music in different sounds and videos
for sure but i just think there's
something inherently loosery about like
trying to promote your documentary on
tick tock when you're literally like the
greatest band of the
80s or one of our yeah no i
i agree i think you know the beatles i
forget who owns their catalog now but
it's a very like
business thing you know yeah i think
it's partially owned by the michael
jackson estate yes
and i maybe even elton john
perhaps i always i was just talking
about that the other day but like so
they're very choosy you know they do
partnerships yeah if you use their song
in a commercial like their whole
catalog is like a
a business enterprise michael jackson
purchased the publishing rights to the
vast majority of the beatles catalog for
47 million dollars out bidding paul
mccartney himself wow that's crazy that
is crazy
okay so yeah exactly like this is the
whole business beatles enterprise
uh this article says he only has it
until 2026.
and then what happens is when paul
mccartney can regain the copyrights to
all of his songs
that's so weird so he just loses the
money he spent or he's made it back and
well he's made it back for sure
well maybe with this move too now maybe
they're getting desperate
this is a desperate move a hundred
percent desperate losery move especially
like either let your songs be like free
let it be let it be free to use on
digital platforms like it doesn't have
to be a big special announcement or like
you know protect
the history of the songs and also just
impregna
you have to protect the integrity of the
beatles yeah honestly them being on tick
tock them doing a disney plus special i
don't know what it's about gorgeous like
that is so premium like
we are in keeping the integrity of the
beatles intact but i don't know pouring
them out on tick tock like
i don't know i don't it just is not
not what i would do
yeah no definitely not
so anyways when you're talking about
yeah gotta do the hey jude the hey jude
challenge or maybe the eleanor rigby
challenge i don't know
um okay wow that was
dense everything kind of took an
emotional toll on i know there were
highs there were lows
aren't you glad we don't have to recap
our scripted shows now
yeah i'm so thankful thank you claudia
you're welcome
um okay so let's do our unscripted tv
recap where we're going to talk about
the real housewives of potomac and the
salt lake city housewives that were on
last night brought to you by third love
we put our bodies through so much
pushing them to the limit for sport
family fashion or just plain fun and
when you think about it it's pretty
incredible that our bodies keep up
third love believes that everybody is
amazing and deserves to be treated that
way because you will fit here with third
love they obsess over each stitch so you
never have to think about how something
feels looks or wears while trends come
and go third love has always stayed true
to one notion we do comfort you do you
they bring the comfort from the sheets
to the streets with the softest
sleepwear luxe washable silk and bras
that you won't take off when you get
home
there are 90 000 5 star reviews um i
just got the pajamas by the way i've had
the bras forever the pajamas are
everything like i was walking around
looking like this like
i don't know like sexy woman yeah i got
the robe and it's so comfortable and i
look like i'm at the salon in my own
home and it's a fabulous look but the
real star of third love is their bras
especially their sizing because they
include exclusive half cups so their
underwear loungewear and activewear all
goes from size extra small to 3x and
they offer the fitting room quiz so if
you've struggled with bras your whole
life it's very possible that you are
wearing the wrong size bra and when i
took my third love quiz like four years
ago i
never knew what my bra size was and it
was just a game changer and the bras
come in all different varieties perfect
for different shirts you can get
different cups it's really like the most
fabulous bra out there
also if you love your fit it's
guaranteed if not they'll exchange and
returns are free for 60 days their team
of expert fit stylists are also
available to chat via text to answer all
of your questions feeling is believing
upgrade to everyday pieces that you love
as much as your body does right now you
can get 20 off your first order at
thirdlove.com
toast that's 20 off at thirdlove.com
toast
thank you claudia all right let's start
with potomac first last night's episode
was very good um i have to say
i feel like the landscape around me is
just changing because like
i'm feeling like confused like honestly
if i was robin and gizelle i 100 would
have left too i had actually a lot of
sympathy for robin like being on my
period
with all these other women and their
husbands my husband's on here i'm
sharing a room with my friend i don't
have a bathroom absolutely not also
giselle does have a broken toe i do
think like i know wendy doesn't like
them she should have been slightly more
gracious no
wendy is so over playing her hands on
the power she's overplayed and she's
actually making robin and gisele look
like sympathetic characters and so yes i
have totally shifted in that regard i
still see robin and giselle and i'm not
like
giving them a pass for everything but in
that situation they were completely
right i would have done the exact same
thing and it's inappropriate to be
walking around the house like going from
the shower and also that's how the
bathroom downstairs is the like communal
bathroom for when they're all hanging
downstairs so like it's disgusting yeah
and that's to be their personal bathroom
and and wendy that doesn't make you look
like cool like you didn't take care of
them it makes you look like a bad
hostess who with poor planning skills
yeah no wendy was not looking her best
this episode she looked like in every in
every situation she's just like so
stubborn
so even in the rooms the hosting
situation like she thinks she's a good
host
on the boat like she can't even have a
conversation with anyone and like you
see the way me and candace are actually
like communicating and finding
resolution and i feel like their
argument was so much deeper than
whatever wendy and robin's issue is yeah
and wendy just like
can't
see past herself she's really making
herself like i'm so bad monique so like
with wendy like is here or there that
doesn't affect like where i stand with
the show but like for a moment she was
not the hero that we deserve but the
hero that we got yeah and now all of
that good work is just being flipped on
its head i completely agree she's like
so butt hurt that rob and gisele are
just like commenting on the way that she
looks being different and by the way not
that i agree with them saying that but
like your reaction is so out of hand now
like like move like that was literally
six weeks ago move on the way that like
karen handles robin and giselle is just
like the right way and so to see like
wendy she's so bothered by them and it's
like it makes her just look
bitter bitter and wrong and in the
stitch like i would 100
if i hadn't left the trip completely i
would 100 have gotten a hotel these are
obviously grown women to be sleeping in
a twin bed with your friend on your
period
on her period with no bathroom and
having to use a downstairs bathroom in a
house where there's people's husbands
is wrong no and this house is very
bizarre because when they pull up it's
so big but like there's literally one
like communal living space and like
one floor of
bedrooms like it's really not that big
yeah i wonder if production stays there
they only have so many rooms to use
but
it's just
wendy is completely wrong in this
situation and robin giselle came off
looking great sympathetic and
wendy did that so i feel like the hero
of the last couple episodes has actually
really been chris bassett like i've
never really thought much of him but
like my god i don't know how he takes
being married to candace she's so
irrational and she just gets so heated
so quickly
and i feel like he does a really good
job of trying to settle her and like
trying to make her see outside her own
[ __ ] like
and i don't know i just kind of love him
in that conversation he had with ashley
like i really appreciate it he knows his
wife is wrong like i think he just like
walks around on eggshells around
everyone like yeah i know my wife said
called you fat i know my wife did this
to you i know my wife did that but he's
just trying to like smooth everything
over with everyone and i actually really
appreciated his
um
his candor when it came to ashley and
i'm sad that the conversation then at
the restaurant turned so bad i had no
idea that candace called michael darby a
slave driver which is
crazy crazy so this is just like time
after time below the belt called her
wide
slave driver mia's big hands me his
mother's low budget your mother's a hoe
it's like
it's kind of like
i'm like done like i was done i think
other people are becoming done which is
you know refreshing to see but then also
i think the craziest part is that at the
end of the night she's in bed with chris
and she was or
she was like that was yesterday today
was fine
what about everything you just burned in
your wake like that's the damage is
still there just delusional that like oh
i can behave like that one day but as
long as if i don't do it the next day
it's as if it didn't happen you know and
the scene where they're really kind of
doing side by sides i think this is from
two weeks ago side by sides of
uh dragging me monique and then throwing
the one piece of lettuce yes mia threw
the whole platter lest we not forget
candace through the first piece it's
always it's a small little instigation
and then obviously the person blows up
because you threw food at them you put
your finger in their face and so i just
i really can't with her anymore like at
all and i really tried yeah no i really
i was coming like i'm in certain
instances and situations like
she doesn't bother me that much i think
some of like her the friendships that
she has are nice whatever but just
if she doesn't get
justice rained down on her at the
reunion like i i can't go two for two on
reunions with no justice okay also
for me the part where i like completely
like left candace last night was when
they finally all sat down in the boat
they're talking about like why you know
mia was talking about why like what she
said hurt
her her mother has been sober for eight
years she was in jail for 10 years um
and then candace is like well when you
said my music video was low budget and
she started to cry like to compare
what she did to mia
to what mia did to her which are
literally not even close to being
somewhere she started to cry i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me like
she like honestly now i just feel like
the entire time she cried at the reunion
last year like fraudulent like just cry
over anything over anything yeah also i
think that mia i actually really like
mia because i'm the one she's like so
messy and
did see that she can't like when she
can't carry bone she comes upstairs like
snitching on what robin said and she
like got it to show up
but then she also like and she owns it
in that moment i'm just like
she's like what yeah and then she owns
it i'm like oh my god she's like so cute
everybody really likes her but then also
i really like how like she was so and i
admire actually that she was so hurt and
offended and like
at a level 10 yeah like i'm done with
this person but she still sat down she
still was like i'm i want to have a
conversation whenever that happens like
she had the conversation and she moved
on from it like that's extremely mature
i could never so to have like one person
encompass all of those things
it's really refreshing she's a great
housewife like i do have to say um
like i i'm glad that they always nip in
the bud that like the game of telephone
got mixed up otherwise it would cause
all these issues you know like you know
um
like i hate when it would go on forever
housewives it's all predicated on did
you say this one word yeah did you call
kim an enabler or whatever did you take
my sister's clothes to death like yes
yes that's the one
um so also i do love mia but her husband
like is kind of annoying and with the
ashley thing at the end of the episode
like ashley's right like leave me alone
we were on the boat all day like i have
to pump like i have a kid can i just
[ __ ] sleep and there's nothing that
grinds my gears more than like when
someone's like you're sleeping like i'm
tired yeah so i'm sleeping yeah i i want
a leg g and it's right now i do
until this particular instance i also
like how mia is just like that's not my
problem no i'm like she's not gonna like
tell him how to live tell him to stop
drinking tell him what to say they're
just like and i think that's actually a
good approach otherwise she would be so
[ __ ] stressed out yeah and it would
like come between them if she was like
please stop because when he's drinking
it's like when he's being annoying and
he's just really annoying and he's an
annoying drunk for sure um
yeah like he picks fights with people
but he's
a grown very grown man like she's not
going to tell him how to live his life
you know also best dress this episode
ascala like she was just looking like a
thank you for mentioning like a gorgeous
model old hollywood glam with the
glasses and the scarf on her head like
she's killing you no but even like her
pajamas she's been killing it but this
episode i think
she shined brighter than ever and you
know when she sat down with robin and
was like i actually another thing that
was a big check in robin's
thing for me she was like i know like i
hate wendy but like you want to be
friends with her like that's fine like
so [ __ ] mature especially then you go
to watch salt lake city and it's like
exactly you can't even talk to each
other exactly claudia i had the same
feelings about robin and i think not to
negate everything that we've ever said
about her but i think it's like when
robin's on her own yes like in her
friendships she's has a really good pov
when she is giselle's sidekick is when
she's at her words that's exactly what
karen hugher said she's like juan should
come because like right now she's just
being like negative with gisele whereas
like if her and one were here they could
have like a good time though i didn't
think she was being negative with jo
i thought that they were being extremely
realistic me too like i didn't think
they were being dramatic no i would have
done the exact same thing
every single time i would have done the
same thing yeah
so yes i had a nice moment with robin me
too
i had a lot of respect for that like i
especially when we're now watching salt
lake city where like literally the crux
of every fight is like well you're my
friend but you're friends with whitney
and i hate whitney like yeah which is so
immature and robin was like i had
wondered like if it was weird that robin
brought a scala on the show and a
scholar like hasn't even been seen with
robin she's actually really good friends
like with the other side karen
um wendy they're like a threesome the
cottage girls you know so i thought i'm
like i wonder if this is going to be a
problem and robin was like so mature
about it i was honestly
impressed impressed
robin and kudos to scala for bringing
fashion to this show it does not go
unnoticed and you know she's working
against the odds here i was you know
what i feel like we've had other
first-time housewives who brought less
to the table
and i'm curious why
they obviously filmed a lot with the
scholar she's on the trip like she was i
feel like she was supposed to be a
full-time housewife and ended up as a
friend of when i actually feel like i
want to know more about scala her
husband is very hot like yeah i want to
know more yeah maybe we'll get that next
season i wonder why it didn't happen but
that's happened a lot before where like
someone's on every trip and then yeah
but you kind of understand like barbara
cat of it like we knew why she didn't
get a full-time housewife role like i
mean we had that with sutton we had that
with um but we knew why sutton had legal
problems yeah we had that with that gen
girl from dallas but honestly like after
seeing her i didn't think that she like
would have been in like an amazing
housewife like i needed to see more but
with the skyla i'm like give me more
yeah
i don't know just a thought just a
thought anyways i really appreciate what
she's bringing to the table um
from a fashion
perspective me too yeah um so it was a
good episode for sure yeah i'm very much
looking forward to
ray and karen
renewing their vows yeah um and then
salt lake city was on and it was pretty
good honestly
the ending was so shook worthy to me
that i actually watched watch watch
robin's live because i needed to see
jenny give some sort of explanation for
like i thought her husband when they
kept showing that in the preview he was
asking for a sister wife was kidding
and because they're not mormon they're
christian or catholic but i didn't
realize in vietnamese culture it's
actually pretty common to be a
polygamous so i thought it was a joke
and then when he was being dead serious
after just like hounding her like how
many more times does she have to say
like i've miscarried nine times i had a
still birth like [ __ ] off yeah i don't
know how many other ways she could say
it and then
i thought he was starting to like
understand a little bit
and then he brought up the sister wife
comment and honestly i don't think i've
ever hated a house husband more than i
hate this man yeah and at first the
conversation went so sideways so fast
because they both have really they both
had
really um
deep
trauma trauma but also like
like
personal opinions about this like i
completely understand where jenny's
coming obviously after speaking hearing
from her husband like i i understand
where he's coming from from too but
jenny's perspective is more important in
my opinion yes of course so i'm sorry
but like [ __ ] off
beyond [ __ ] off when she was on watch
what happened side and she just summed
it up it's like you know obviously when
you're young you have these ideas like i
want a big family but then like life
happens and you know
and two kids feels like a million no and
she has three kids right yeah no so like
no everyone says like yeah i want to
have a thousand kids no but it's not
even i want to have a thousand kids like
you if you can't sometimes that just
doesn't happen for you and like he's
still living in the past of like where's
my big family and it's like
look around these are it's over this is
the reality of the situation yeah i
think she's like and watch what happens
live she had a very um good perspective
take on it so i'm hoping that they've
moved on from this sister wife comment i
don't know how you do
but
she seemed like she
was like they've reached some sort of
when she was telling meredith and lisa
about her
stillborn birth
i have to say i literally cried so hard
and then when i had a real 180 degree
moment with lisa barlow when she was in
her confessionals and she was like i've
actually heard the story like i've known
this about about jenny and then she
started to cry i was like you know what
lisa barlow's a good friend she is an
empathetic no i am turning around lest
we not forget when last season when
meredith told her that her and seth were
separating and she started crying like
she is a good friend i want to say this
episode i have i'm completely turned on
lisa barlow in a positive direction i
was until that meal
no no okay jackie that was fraudulence
and i'm a i'm putting it all out i'm a
whitney stan oh my god for her just
calling it out being like are you
kidding me this is so staged it was i
i still really like whitney but like
there was points in the lisa column
after last night's episode and i didn't
feel like i had points in the whitney
column let me just explain if i may
first of all when lisa took her to um
whiskey and pie or gin and pie which was
like a really cute date lisa was very i
felt
direct honest she didn't really like
try to pretend like i think maybe she
did try to like obfuscate you know i
never had an issue with you but then
eventually she gets real and is like
right you know we've had issues
let's move forward i i know i can be
people think that they know how i'm
thinking or feeling and i do feel like
we always feel like we know like oh
lisa's really thirsty like this yeah and
i just don't feel like we know lisa i
she's just way more interesting
and complex than layered than i had
previously thought so i really liked her
directing
her take on reconciling with whitney so
it's like we don't need to go through
everything i ever said yeah i'm sure she
talked some trash i'm sure she thought
whitney and heather were basic and that
they weren't cool like her and uh
meredith and jen sure but you know what
whitney's here to stay lisa gets it now
can we move forward sorry and she did
apologize like she wasn't just i thought
she was going to be a lot more
hard-headed because also that's what the
previous [ __ ] like she was like laughing
in whitney's face yeah
so i was like okay you know what i like
how lisa barlow does an apology pai
looks great
jyn's looking good i'm here for it
then she's such a good friend to
jenny and i'm just like feeling her as a
person and then in the situation at the
restaurant i don't think that it was
meant to be a setup i think i don't know
what the name of the the owner aubry
mm-hmm someone said audrey it's angie
okay then aubry an aubry yeah
aubry so did you see the dms from last
week i did that okay after last week's
episode that some dms went you know on
the internet from the restaurant owner
saying lisa did not tell us to cancel
angie's event we had already planned to
film at our restaurant like with product
with bravo they were gonna have like a
cast event at our restaurant and it was
just a matter of like we're doing this
instead of that not
so
i came at it from this perspective of
like they had plans to film at aubrey's
new restaurant lisa's going to support
her friends it's where her tequila is
it's just like i think
it just so happens that there's you know
not so many restaurant tours
and restaurants they're going to go to i
thought i'm glad that whitney called it
out but i'm also glad that they moved on
because it was too stupid no and you
know what lisa probably did want like i
do i do believe lisa's genuine and
wanting to be friends with whitney and i
think that the fact that their husbands
are so close is so cute and i love the
idea of them go but we literally saw
them hang out three times in this
episode like i loved it
um but i do think she probably was
genuine in that but also wanted to like
clear her name and her friend's name so
she's like oh this is my friend this is
her restaurant she can you believe what
angie said about me like it was so
staged i love that lisa called it i mean
that heather called it out but i also
i'm glad that they got past it because i
i do really stay on this friendship yeah
me too and also i just want to put all
of it on aubry like angie
no angie oh you want to put it on the
restaurant we're gonna put it all in the
restaurant tour like she came over like
you don't need to be serving the food
right let them like the restaurant was
getting such good press the food looked
so good the drinks were so good you
didn't need to come over you didn't need
to bring up angie and you ruined this
beautiful night and so even if lisa
barlow is complicit i'm putting it all
on aubry i mean her acting
was
lisa
can you believe what angie said she
really thought she was doing some
auditioning for the show
and for that reason i'm glad whitney
called her out and put in the end to the
madness
but i just want even if there is blame
on lisa's shoulders i'm putting it all
on aubrey so that i can move forward
with a clean conscience okay
i really do love this friendship i hope
it stays and i just i ca i can't even
tell you how much i love salt lake city
like the fact that whitney like is going
to the gym and there's just like
mountains in the background like could
you imagine no it's so gorgeous it's so
gorgeous oh lisa and heather are going
to go talk about the birds and the bees
let's start with the skiing yeah even uh
when jenny had that atrocious
conversation with her husband they were
skiing no they were like doing um cross
country that looked so miz that's the
worst part of skiing is like walking
around
the flat who would make a whole sport of
it psychos psychos um
so yeah i feel like it was actually a
very low-key episode like the whitney
heather stuff was really the the main
lisa
yeah that's what i meant um but you know
what mary's home scenes are just getting
like so sad and so dark mary and lisa
playing tennis was no meredith
honestly like i can't we can't get their
names it's monday
meredith and mary playing tennis was
just like so hysterical they both looked
amazing meredith playing in a fur coat
and she shows up and neither boots yeah
it was but she looked so stunning mary
in her tom brown outfit like i can't um
and i felt like they were having two
different conversations where like
meredith thought we were just like
complaining about her hus our husbands
and like their weird quirks and mary was
just like i hate myself no we live in
separate wings like yeah i i'm forcing
my son to live with us because i don't
want to be alone with him no and i'm not
joking yeah um like doesn't robert
senior watch the show like that's the
only thing no i think mary says a [ __ ]
to his face like if you changed
everything about you i would be in love
with you stop for sure so
i don't know where they go from here
like they just like have one like a
marriage just you know very like
downtown yeah rooms like we're just
partners but like in this day and age
like once your kids out of the house
like what do you do and that's actually
when a lot of people in this day and age
like do end up getting divorced like
when the kids are gone you like look at
each other and you're like what the [ __ ]
do we even have in common anymore that
brings me back to a main theme in the
book i just read party crasher
which is which is they had you know
kids grown up divorced and then the kids
were all like that's when everything was
a lie and then like the women like have
this like renaissance and like find
themselves again like it's like a nancy
meyers movie yeah um it's like
everything yeah no but sometimes you
think it's best for the kids to like
wait but then the kids are like wait so
you were just lying the whole time right
right and that messes with the kids too
so like do you think it's better to be
children of divorce like at our age when
it was we were like 11. or like when
you're
27. i actually feel like younger is
better i think it's it just it's like
either way could be bad and you can like
blame all your issues on it it just
depends on the kid not the time no but
if you're like in the process of like
dating getting engaged getting married
and your parents get divorced and like
it's your whole foundation for like love
oh that's really messed up that like is
very difficult to deal with so like
honestly i would prefer being 11. like i
remember like if you read in my new york
times bestselling novel
girlfriendjob.com book um i really don't
remember giving a shred of a [ __ ] that
my parents were getting divorced but
some people it's like the thing that
breaks them like they never recover from
it yeah yeah that's true but when you
all but like when you're an adult and
your parents get divorced like you have
you're you know in your own
life and apartment and
it doesn't affect your day-to-day as
much whereas when you're a kid like it
it could mean moving that's true there's
a lot of upheaval that's true but also
if you're like twenty seconds i think
you need to know your kids
you know what yeah yeah because like if
you're 27 and like you're dating and
like you've looked up to your parents
forever and like that is the foundation
of what you believe a healthy
relationship to be and then it just
becomes comes crumbling down like
how do we get to this conversation
oh mary mary okay no but it's an
interesting thing
and i think i would prefer to be a child
of divorce at age 11 even though then
it's like all the kids are like looking
at you like who [ __ ] cares no and i
was just reading about it and thinking
about it and basically the reason why
the main character in the book like so
she's 25 maybe and her parents are
getting divorced and she cannot handle
it oh my god she like loses her [ __ ]
mind right so when like honestly i know
it's very triggering for a lot of people
but like it really is not a big deal
like your parents are both alive like
not to rub it in but like come on
no but see honestly
i really feel
like
i think being younger is
better also because like i'm sorry kids
they need some things to go through in
order to have a personality like that
that's a really good point you got to
build character like not everything can
be easy for the kids the kids need
adversity 100 i think adversity is the
best thing that ever happened to me a
hundred percent i would agree i think
like the universe took a little far with
like killing my father but before that i
think it was good yeah no you got to
crank up the adversity
and things it shouldn't always be easy
that's like that's how your kid becomes
like a spoiled [ __ ] brat it's true
but it's like as a parent like you just
want to protect and explore everything
in this kitchen never know of course of
course of course you know it's so true
it's like a balance of like wanting them
to have a really easy wonderful great
life but also like you don't want them i
want to see like interesting
well-rounded human beings and you have
to go through things in order to be a
person with something to say yeah
so that's your real solid city recap
and that's just you know a little bit
about being a parent no i mean you're
literally about to be one like i know it
makes you think it does you need to like
set up like you should like set up fake
obstacles so that like you know the
stakes aren't that like when i think of
kayla and she's like standing up i'm
like
push up just push her down so she can
know what it's like to fall try again is
she gonna get back up she's too
successful
she's too successful
it's terrible
um okay that was the real housewives
recap that was our show that was some
parenting advice yeah
god can't wait to we're like we're
obviously gonna be doing the show
forever so like when we actually have
kids like who have like you know like
problems and [ __ ] like the show's gonna
be so funny hysterical but are we gonna
like really air out our kids dirty
laundry on the podcast 100 it depends on
the stain it depends on the kids
um that's our show you guys thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
monday morning show where we deliver the
fast fast stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasting we found so it's
spotify itunes stitch or public video i
have ready to catch box all the places
sweaty listen podcast five nice morning
until 7 star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing day and if you made it
to the end of this episode
congratulations in honor of james
corden's mega flop cats why don't you
leave a cat emoji on our most recent
instagram you'll be okay with that so
many cats running around yeah we're just
the cutest cats aren't we the cutest
cats bye bye